- - We will win!
- - Des politiciens rallient
leles troupes pour resserrer
l'l'accès aux armes à feu.
AÀ l'intérieur du Capitole
auaussi, l'émotion est forte.
DeDes survivants témoignent
dede leur détresse.
MiMiah, 10 ans, était dans
lala classe de 4e année
lolors de la fusillade d'Uvalde.
"L"Le tueur a tiré sur mon ami
àà côté de moi. J'ai mis
dede son sang sur moi
etet j'ai fait la morte."
SoSon père est venu à Washington
popour dire aux élus d'agir.
"J"J'ai failli perdre mon bébé",
a-a-t-il dit en larmrmes.
LeLe massacre d'Uvalde a fait
2121 morts. L'arme d'assaut
ututilisée par l le tueur,
unun AR-R-15 avec un chargeur à
grgrande capacité, a littéralemt
pupulvérisé le corps
dede certains enfants.
"C"C'était excessivement
didifficile de les identifier",
a a dit ce médecin.
EtEt puis, dans la salle,
l'l'émotion et la tristesse
onont cédé leur place à la colè.
CeCette femme a perdu un enfant
lolors de la fusillade survenue
dadans un centre commercial
àà Buffalo.
"L"L'Amérique, dit-elle,
esest profondément violente.
CÇa fait partie de la culture."
LeLes chiffres sont d'ailleurs
imimpressionnants. Le comité
dudu Congrès avait t ce tableau
enen toile de fond.
OnOn constate que les fusillades
auaux Étatats-Unis, en 2019,
dédépassent largement le total
dedes tueries dans l'ensemble
dedes autres pays du G7.
CeCette maman, qui a perdu
soson enfant, réclame de l'acti.
ElElle veut l'interdiction
dedes ventes d'armes d'assaut...
ElElle demande aussi que l'âge
lélégal pour se procurer une are
d'd'assaut passe de 18 à 21 anst
quque les lois soient plus sévès
popour vérifier les antécédents
dedes acheteurs d'armes.
EtEt elle n'est pas seule.
LeLes démocrates, le président
BiBiden en tête, poussent
popour des changements.
LeLes négociations se poursuive.
IlIl faudra toutefois une entene
avavec les républicains au Séna.
M Martine, personne ne peut
rerester indifférent à
ceces témoignages tellement
dédéchirants. Reste que
leles négociations, elles sont
exextrêmement difficiles entre
dédémocrates et républicains?
MAMARTINE BIRON, @M_Biron
- - Il y a eu un petit vent
d'd'optimisme ce matin, mais qui
s's'est vite dissipé, alors
ququ'il a été déposé au Congrès
unun projet de loi pour interdie
lala vente d'armes d'assaut aux
jejeunes de moins de 21 ans.
V Vous savez qu'ici, aux
EtEtats-Unis, les jeunes de 18 s
nene peuvent pas acheter de biè,
nene peuvent pas acheter de
cicigarettes, mais ils peuvent
acacheter des armemes d'assaut c
unun chargeur à grande capacité.
MaMais on s'est rendu compte asz
rarapidement que le projet de li
n'n'irait pas très loin, parce
quque, au Sénat, il manque l'api
d'd'une dizaine de sénateurs
rérépublicains. Alors, ça n'allt
nunulle part, le seul espoir qui
reste finalement en fin de
jojournée, c'est que
leles négociations bipartisanes
vovont se poursuivre.
- - Oui. C'est déjà ça, mais c't
unun débat qui divise tellement
lele pays. Il y a deux visions i
s's'afaffrontent vraiment?
- - Oui. Bien, les démocrates
pepensent que plus il y a de
tutueries, plus il faut limiter
l'l'accès aux armes. Mais
leles républicains pensent plutt
quque plus il y a de tueries,
plplus il faut permettre l'accès
auaux armes pour q que
leles Américains puissent se
prprotéger. C'est sûr qu'il y a
dedes nuances de gris dans ce qe
jeje viens de vous dire, mais
grgrosso modo, c c'est ça le dé.
EtEt les Américains... et
l'l'opinion publique,
elelle est divivisée. Les sondas
sosont à 50-50. Alors, quand
onon regarde ça, on peut dire,
cece soir, que ça risque de
prprendre un bon moment avant
ququ'il y ait un changement
sisignificatif.
- - Oui, s'il y en a u